SPEEDWAY.
>> I WAS A LITTLE WOOZEY AFTER
MY SHOT.
>>> SPEAKING OF SHOTS, WE'RE
BEGINNING NOW WITH ANOTHER BIG
STEP OF GETTING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND BACK TO NORMAL
LIFE.
THE FDA IS EXPANDING ITS
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION FOR
THE PFIZER CORONAVIRUS VACCINE.
PFIZER SAID ITS VACCINE IS 100%
EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING ILLNESS
FOR THAT AGE GROUP.
THE DECISION WILL ALLOW 17
MILLION MORE AMERICANS TO HAVE
THE VACCINE IF THEY WANT IT.
>> THE CDC IS EXPECTED TO GIVE
APPROVAL TOMORROW CLEARIN THE
WAY FOR SHOTS TO BE GIVEN.
MORE THAN 261 MILLION COVID
VACCINES HAVE BEEN ADMINISTERED
ACROSS THE U.S.
AND CDC SAYS 35% OF AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN FULLY VACCINATED.
>> WE'RE JOINED NOW BY
DR. WILLIAM GRUBER.
HE IS PFIZER'S SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF VACCINE DEVELOPMENT
AND ALSO A PEDIATRICIAN.
DR. GRUBER, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU'RE THE PERFECT PERSON TO
TALK TO US ABOUT WITH THIS
MORNING.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> YWE'RE GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
SO MANY ADULTS ARE HESITANT TO
GET THE VACCINE.
HOW IN THE WORLD DO YOU CONVINCE
THEM TO LET THEIR KIDS GET IT.
EARLIER IN THE NEWSCAST, WE HAD
SOMEBODY THAT SAID PARENTS NEED
TO BE ENCOURAGED AND THEY NEED
INCENTIVE.
WHAT'S YOUR BEST PITCH TO THE
PARENTS OUT THERE?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THE FIRST BEST PITCH, OF
COURSE, THE FDA HAS NOW
AUTHORIZED EMERGENCY USE FOR
ADOLESCENTS 12 TO 15 YEARS OF
AGE WHICH BUILDS THE LARGE GROUP
OF INDIVIDUALS FOR WHICH THE
VACCINE IS AUTHORIZED.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
12 YEARS OF AGE AND UP.
THERE ARE REALLY THREE THINGS.
THIS AFFORDS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTECT THE ADOLESCENT AGAINST
COVID-19, ALTHOUGH THEY LESS
COMMONLY HAVE SEVERE DISEASE,
THEY CAN END UP IN THE HOSPITAL.
IT ALLOWS US TO MAKE A MAJOR
STEP FORWARD IN TERMS OF HERD
PROTECTION, TO PROTECT ALL OF
US.
AND AN IMPORTANTLY IT ALLOWS
ADOLESCENTS TO GET BACK TO BEING
ADOLESCENTS TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
IN SPORTING ACTIVITIES.
TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN DRAMA
CLUB OR GATHER IN GROUPS.
SO IT REALLY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL LIFE.
>> ALL OF THAT SOUNDS GOOD.
WE'VE ALL HEARD THOSE ARGUMENTS
BEFORE AND PEOPLE STILL AREN'T
THERE.
WHAT'S THE DOWNSIDE?
THERE ALWAYS SEEM TO BE A DOWN
J
SIDES WITH THESE PTHING.
>> VERY LITTLE IN THE WAY OFDOWN
SIDES, YOUR COMMENTATOR EARLIER
SAID SOMETIMES THERE'S FEVER AND
FATIGUE AND CHILLS JUST LIKE IN
OLDER INDIVIDUALS AS WELL.
BUT THIS IS A SMALL PRICE TO PAY
FOR PROTECTION TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL LIFE.
>> DR. GRUBER, WHEN WE SAY THE
VACCINE IS 100% EFFECTIVE, WHAT
EXACTLY DID THAT MEAN?
DOES THAT MEAN IF YOU'RE 12 TO
15 YEARS OLD AND YOU GET THIS
SHOT Y WILL NOT GET SICK FROM
COVID?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS
MEANS.
THAT'S WHAT WE OBSERVED IN THE
CLINICAL TRIAL.
WE HAD ZERO CASES IN THE VACCINE
RECIPIENTS AND 18 IN THOSE THAT
RECEIVED PLACEBO.
SO, WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED THAT
THE VACCINE IS LIKELY TO HAVE
HIGH EFFICACY.
OF COURSE, THERE MAY BE
BREAKTHROUGH CASES CERTAINLY,
WHAT WE OBSERVED IS 100%
EFFICACY AND GIVES CONFIDENCE
THAT THE VACCINE IS LIKELY TO
WORK.
>> DR. GRUBER, PFIZER'S TRIALS
FOR 6 MONTHS OLD ARE ONGOING.
WHAT, IF ANYTHING, IS DIFFERENT
ABOUT THOSE TRIALS?
>> YEAH, SO, THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION.
WE OBVIOUSLY ARE VERY ATTENTIVE
TO BEING DELIBERATE AND CAREFUL,
AS WE MOVE DOWN IN AGE.
IT MAY WELL BE THE CASE THAT THE
CURRENT DOSE THAT WE USE IN
ADULTS AND 12 TO 15 YEAR OLDS WE
NEED TO REDUCE FOR YOUNGER
CHILDREN.
SO, WE'VE GRADUALLY MOVED DOWN
IN AGE FROM 5 TO 11 YEAR OLDS.
TO 2 TO 4-YEAR-OLDS FROM 6
MONTHS TO 2-YEAR-OLDS.
WORKING WITH A SMALL DOSE AND
WORKING UP IN DOSE.
UNTIL WE GET TO THAT GOLDILOCKS
SPOT JUST RIGHT PROVIDING THE
AMOUNT TOLERATED.
>> AND WHEN DO YOU THINK THOSE
RESULTS WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE TRIALS?
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE'LL HAVE RESULTS IN
THE FALL FROM OUR CHILDREN THAT
WE'RE VACCINATING IN THESE
TRIALS THAT ARE 2 YEARS OF AGE
AND UP.
AND PROBABLY LATE AT THE END OF
THE YEAR OR BEGINNING OF 2022,
FOR CHILDREN 6 MONTHS TO 2 YEARS
OF AGE.
>> WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF BOOSTER SHOTS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
WHAT DETERMINES WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING TO NEED A BOOSTER SHOT OR
NOT?
AND WHEN WILL YOU NEED A BOOSTER
SHOT?
>> YES.
SO, WE ACTUALLY HAVE ONGOING
STUDIES TO LOOK AT TWO THINGS.
ONE, TO DETERMINE WHETHER A
BOOSTER SHOT CAN PROVIDE AN
IMMUNE RESPONSE THAT WILL
PROVIDE PROTECTION JUST LIKE THE
FIRST TWO DOSE.
WE'RE ALSO, OF COURSE, LOOKING
AT THAT MAKING SURE THAT DOSE IS
WELL TOLERATED.
AND THEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
POPULATION THAT'S ALREADY
RECEIVED TWO DOSES OF VACCINE TO
DETERMINE HOW LONG THAT
PROTECTION LASTS.
AND THE COMBINATION OF THAT
INFORMATION WILL INFORM US AND
THE CDC AND THE FDA ABOUT THE
BEST TIME FOR A BOOSTER.
>> HOW LONG HOW LONG DO YOU
THINK IT WILL BE BEFORE WE KNOW
WHETHER WE NEED A BOOSTER SHOT?
>> I THINK WE'LL HAVE SOME
INFORMATION AS EARLY AS THE END
OF THE SUMMER, OR EARLY FALL, IN
TIME TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR OFFERING UP A
BOOSTER.
BUT IT MAY WELL BE THE CASE OF
THAT THE VACCINE PROVIDES MORE
DURABLE PROTECTION.
AND A BOOSTER MIGHT NOT BE
NEEDED FOR UP TO A YEAR.
>> SO, RIGHT NOW, WE DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG THE VACCINE LASTS?
>> WE KNOW THAT IT LASTS AT
LEAST UP TO SIX MONTHS.
WE HAVE GOOD DATA THAT WE'VE
PRESENTED PUBLICLY.
AND WE'LL BE PUBLISHING SHORTLY
THAT INDICATES THAT UP TO SIX
MONTHS THE VACCINE HAS VERY HIGH
EFFICACY.
>> ALL